que nous avons propagée
et que nous semblons ne pas réussir à reconnaître ou éradiquer.
PV : Nous n'en sommes pas encore là.
Nous sommes ici aujourd'hui
pour améliorer nos standards en termes d'éducation raciale,
pour redéfinir ce que cela signifie d'être instruit en matière raciale.
WG : Nous voulons que partout à travers les États-Unis,
les plus jeunes et les générations futures grandissent en étant dotés
des outils pour comprendre, naviguer et améliorer
un monde structuré par la division raciale.
Nous voulons que nous voyions tous la communauté comme un endroit
où nous nous sentons fiers de nos propres origines,
mais aussi où nous pouvons investir dans les expériences des autres
comme si c'étaient les nôtres.
PV : Nous avons obtenu notre baccalauréat en juin dernier.
WG : Vous pourriez penser --
(Applaudissements)
Vous pourriez penser qu'après 12 ans,
quelqu'un en classe ou en dehors nous aurait aidées à comprendre --
PV : Au moins de façon basique --
WG : La société où nous vivons.
PV : Presque tous nos camarades ne la comprennent pas.
WG : Dans les communautés à travers notre pays,
tant d'entre elles étant racialement divisées,
PV : Si vous ne cherchez pas une éducation raciale,
une alphabétisation raciale,
WG : Vous n'en aurez pas.
Cela ne viendra pas seul.
PV : Même avec des conversations au sujet de la race,
notre compréhension a toujours été superficielle.
Nous avons réalisé qu'il y avait deux grandes lacunes
dans notre éducation raciale.
WG : Un, la lacune du cœur :
une incapacité à comprendre chacune de nos expériences,
à faire preuve de compassion de façon acharnée et sans réserve,
sans se contenter de belles paroles.
PV : Deux, la lacune de l'esprit :
une incapacité à comprendre comment le racisme fonctionne
de façon plus générale et systémique.
WG : Un, la lacune du cœur.
Pour être honnête, les questions de race ont fait surface quelques fois à l'école.
Nous défendons notre éducation en justice sociale
car nous avons entendu parler de Martin Luther King,
d'Harriet Tubman et de Rosa Parks.
Même dans toutes ces conversations,
les questions de race semblaient dépassées :
« L'esclavage, c'est arrivé il y a bien longtemps,
mais cela importe-t-il maintenant ? »
En conséquence, cela nous importait peu.
Et si notre professeur avait présenté un témoignage contemporain,
par exemple, comment Treniya nous a dit qu'à Pittsburgh --
PV : « Ma sœur était sur Facebook et a cherché notre nom de famille.
Ce mec blanc est apparu
et nous avons découvert
que son arrière-arrière-grand-père avait des esclaves
et mon arrière-arrière-arrière- grand-mère en faisait partie.
Mon nom de famille -- ce n'est pas mon identité.
Nous vivons avec le nom d'un homme blanc.
S'il n'y avait pas eu d'esclavage, qui serais-je ? »
WG : Cela semble pertinent, immédiat,
parce que le lien à l'héritage durable de l'esclavage est clair.
Et si notre professeur nous donnait ces statistiques impersonnelles ?
Vous les avez probablement vues à la une.
PV : Le taux d'incarcération des Afro-américains
est cinq fois plus important que celui des Blancs.
WG : Considérez Ronnie, à Seattle.
PV : « Mon père, c'est tout pour moi.
Il est tout ce que j'ai, je ne connais pas ma mère.
Mon père est incarcéré à tort depuis 12 ans.
J'ai une fille et j'essaye d'être cette même figure paternelle pour elle :
toujours impliqué dans ce qu'elle fait, c'est même agaçant parfois.
Mais j'ai peur de disparaître de sa vie,
comme mon père a disparu de la mienne. »
WG : Ne donner que les statistiques, seulement les faits,
sans les rattacher à de vrais humains,
peut mener à une compréhension dangereusement incomplète de ces faits.
Cela ne reconnaît pas que pour beaucoup de ceux ne comprenant pas le racisme,
ce n'est pas l'absence de connaissances
qui empêche de parler
de la douleur de la suprématie et l'oppression des Blancs,
ils ne reconnaissent pas que l'existence de cette douleur.
Ils ne reconnaissent pas que des êtres humains sont affectés
et ils ne le ressentent pas assez pour que cela leur importe.
PV : Deux, la lacune de l'esprit.
Nous ne pouvons pas ignorer les statistiques.
Nous ne pouvons pas comprendre la situation de Ronnie
sans comprendre comment des choses
comme des lois injustes, une police ayant des préjugés,
un racisme systémique ont engendré
le taux d'incarcération disproportionné au fil du temps.
Ou comment à Honolulu,
l'importante population carcérale d'indigènes hawaïens comme Kimmy
est fortement influencée par la longue histoire de l'île
de colonisation américaine,
son effet passant de génération en génération jusqu'à aujourd'hui.
Nous parlions parfois
d'expériences personnelles et uniques en classe.
Comment Justin nous a dit --
WG : « Je travaille à reconquérir psychologiquement ma place dans la ville.
Pour moi, mon Chicago n'est pas la belle architecture du centre-ville,
ni le nord de Chicago.
Mon Chicago, c'est la ligne orange,
la ligne rose, les immigrants de la classe ouvrière
qui prennent le train. »
PV : Si nous n'avions pu connaître son expérience personnelle,
nous n'aurions pas parlé de comment le redlining
et la ségrégation légalisée du passé
ont créé les quartiers racialement divisés dans lesquels nous vivons aujourd'hui.
Nous n'aurions pas complètement compris
comment le racisme est incrusté
dans la structure de tout ce qui nous entoure
car nous resterions strictement concentrés sur les expériences isolées des gens.
Un autre exemple, Sandra de Washington DC nous a raconté :
WG : « Quand je suis avec ma famille coréenne,
je sais comment me comporter.
Je sais quoi faire pour qu'ils sentent que je tiens à eux.
Préparer et partager à manger
est l'un des moyens fondamentaux d'exprimer son amour.
Quand je suis avec mon partenaire, qui n'est pas coréen,
nous avons dû tenir compte du fait
que je me concentre beaucoup sur la nourriture et pas lui.
Un jour, il a dit qu'il ne voulait pas que j'attende de lui
qu'il me prépare à manger
et cela m'a vraiment bouleversée. »
PV : Cela peut sembler être une réaction étrange,
seulement si nous ne reconnaissons pas que c'est emblématique
de quelque chose de plus vaste, de plus profond.
Un traumatisme intergénérationnel.
Comment dans la famille de Sandra, la famine et la pauvreté
a existé jusqu'à la génération des parents de Sandra
et influence donc Sandra aujourd'hui.
Ce qu'elle ressent quand quelqu'un dit :
WG : « Je ne veux pas te nourrir. »
PC : C'est :
WG : « Je ne veux pas t'enlacer. »
PV : Sans cette compréhension nuancée qu'elle et son partenaire ont
de sa réaction et du contexte historique sous-jacent,
cela pourrait facilement mener à une dispute inutile.
C'est pourquoi il est si important que, de façon proactive, nous
(Les deux ensemble) : Co-créons
PV : Une culture américaine commune
qui identifie et adopte les différentes valeurs et normes
dans nos différentes communautés.
WG : Pour être racialement instruit,
PV : Pour comprendre qui nous sommes afin de guérir ensemble --
WG : Nous ne pouvons pas négliger le cœur
PV : Ni l'esprit.
Avec nos centaines de témoignages,
nous avons décidé de publier un manuel d'éducation raciale
pour combler ce fossé entre notre cœur et notre esprit.
WG : Notre livre « L'index de la salle de classe »
fait part de témoignages très personnels.
PV : Et lie ces témoignages personnels
aux recherches excellentes de statisticiens et d'experts.
WG : Chaque jour, nous sommes époustouflées
par les expériences des gens,
par la complexité de notre réalité raciale collective.
PV : Aujourd'hui, nous vous demandons :
WG : Êtes-vous racialement instruit ?
En êtes-vous déjà là ?
PV : Comprenez-vous vraiment les gens qui vous entourent,
leurs histoires, de telles histoires ?
Il ne suffit pas de savoir que Louise de Seattle
a survécu aux camps d'internement des Japonais-américains.
Il faut savoir que, pendant ce temps,
son mari était l'un des 33 000 Japonais-américains
qui se sont battus pour notre pays durant cette guerre,
un pays qui, simultanément, internait leurs familles.
Pour la plupart d'entre nous,
ces Japonais-américains dans les camps et en service
voient leur courage, leur résistance, leur histoire être oubliés.
Ils ne sont devenus que des victimes.
PV : Il ne suffit pas de savoir que les mariages interraciaux
comme celui de Shermaine et Paul de Washington existent.
Il faut reconnaître que notre société a été programmée pour qu'ils échouent.
Que lors de leur premier rendez-vous, quelqu'un a crié :
« Pourquoi es-tu avec cette pute noire ? »
Que d'après une étude de Columbia sur les relations cisgenres hétérosexuelles,
noir est souvent assimilé à la masculinité
et asiatique à la féminité,
menant plus d'hommes à ne pas estimer les femmes noires
et à avoir un fétichisme pour les femmes asiatiques.
Parmi les mariages noir-blanc datant de l'année 2000,
73% avaient un mari noir et une femme blanche.
Paul et Shermaine défient cette statistique.
Être noir, c'est magnifique,
mais il faut beaucoup d'efforts pour le croire
quand la société dit le contraire.
WG : Il ne suffit pas de savoir que les gens blancs comme Lisa de Chicago
ont des privilèges de Blancs.
Il faut réfléchir consciemment sur le terme « blanc » et son histoire,
savoir que « blanc » ne peut pas être assimilé à « américain ».
C'est savoir que Lisa ne peut pas oublier son histoire familiale personnelle
d'oppression juive,
comment, en grandissant,
on l'a traitée de « sale juive avec des cornes et une queue ».
Mais Lisa sait qu'elle peut passer pour blanche
et qu'elle bénéficie d'énormes privilèges systémiques et interpersonnels
alors elle passe ses journées
à chercher des moyens de mettre à profit ce privilège blanc
pour la justice sociale.
Par exemple, en lançant des conversations
avec d'autres gens privilégiés au sujet de la race.
Ou en donnant le pouvoir à ses élèves en classe
en apprenant à écouter leurs expériences de racisme et de pauvreté.
PV : Il ne suffit pas de savoir que les langues autochtones se meurent.
C'est apprécier comment la maîtrise du cherokee,
que moins de 12 000 personnes parlent aujourd'hui,
est un acte de survie, de préservation de la culture et de l'histoire.
C'est savoir comment le cherokee, langue n'ayant pas de genres,
a permis l'acceptation d'Ahyoka en tant que femme transgenre
à Tahlequah, en Oklahoma.
Sa grand-mère lui a dit fermement un adage en cherokee :
« Je ne me dis pas qui tu es,
tu me dis qui tu es.
Et c'est qui tu es. »
WG : Ce ne sont que des extraits de quelques histoires.
Il y a environ 323 millions de personnes aux États-Unis.
PV : Et 7,4 milliards de personnes sur Terre.
WG : Il y a beaucoup à écouter.
PV : Et beaucoup à apprendre.
PV : Nous devons aller plus loin.
WG : Rehausser le niveau d'éducation raciale.
Car sans investir en une éducation qui apprécie
WG : Les histoires PV : Et les statistiques,
WG : Les gens PV : Et les chiffres,
WG : L'interpersonnel PV : Et le systémique,
WG : Il manquera toujours un élément.
PV : Aujourd'hui, si peu d'entre nous se comprennent.
WG : Nous ne savons pas communiquer,
PV : Vivre ensemble, WG : Aimer l'autre.
Nous devons créer ensemble une nouvelle communauté nationale.
PV : Une nouvelle culture commune alliant souffrance et célébration.
WG : Nous devons commencer par apprendre dans nos communautés locales,
combler le fossé entre notre cœur et notre esprit
pour s'éduquer racialement.
PV : Quand nous le ferons tout, nous serons plus proches
d'une vie dans des lieux et systèmes
qui se battent et s'occupent de nous tous de la même manière.
WG : Aucun d'entre nous ne restera en marge.
PV : Désolée papa et maman, l'université peut attendre.
WG : Nous avons une année de césure pour voyager dans les 50 États
et recueillir des témoignages.
PV : Il nous reste 23 États à interviewer.
(Les deux ensemble) Mettons-nous au travail.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)